all right he's a pro football hall of
famer he's one of my uh my favorites
i've known him
damn near 20 years now and uh
his new uh bus stops here foundation is
the launching the second session of
check in
a virtual youth program designed for
middle school age students who as we all
know
um there's a lot of remote learning
going on in this country right now
because of the pandemic our buddy jerome
betta stops by on the rich eisen show
how you doing jb
hey rich how you doing sir better for
talking to you how's your family
everybody good
everybody's doing well we're all safe
and and uh just keeping our heads on the
ground
okay you're just catching up on your
rich eisen shows during the pandemics
oh my gosh could you imagine playing in
this right now this would be
very scary i'm asthmatic so
this would be a very difficult decision
for me to have to decide
to play or not so it this would this
would be a scary one but
the football side of me i think would
want to win out because
you know you want to play yeah and
that's what you love to do but um
your health is is is you know paramount
course
it's scary well it's not just that too
it's it's what you might be bringing
back into
the house to your kids your spouse to
anybody in your family that's uh of a
certain age
and and i do not begrudge a single
opt-out
not a singer no not one because we don't
know their scenario in their situation
everyone's unique and and their
situation is unique
and we can't assume all you just don't
want to play uh
yeah you all want to play but it's not
necessarily worth the risk
you've got to weigh it all yeah i know
and obviously for for
for college we don't know kids um and
how it might affect
um anybody uh despite being 18 or 21 or
22 and it just
i i just don't know how college is doing
it i know your alma mater's gone online
for the first two weeks they made that
announcement but it does appear that uh
notre dame football might still go
though
that's the scary part about big you know
the big big business and
football and college football you know
you you saw
what the big ten do you saw what the
pac-12 did
uh and then it created a pretty much a
rift now
you know these schools that are are
predominantly in the southern states are
saying hey we're going to continue
on and and now you know it creates a
a really uneven playing field because
now you got high school recruits looking
at this decision
saying well maybe i need to rethink that
and look at a school
here uh so possibly i can play
next year if if if this happens again so
this is a big problem that they
they've got to try to fix not not only
to mention that
the health uh you know scenario for
these kids that that they're going to be
out on the field is still
very dangerous jerome bettis pro
football hall of famer here
on the rich island show i don't know if
we've had a chance to talk since caller
got in
uh no i don't think so you know i mean
what what is your
what is your bust going to say to his
when the lights go out
my bus would it would say coach you know
you should have got me the ball just a
little bit more
okay you should have got it to me a
little bit more man
well i mean why why do you think he's
hall of fame worthy
jb i mean you know uh he he um
he got in along with jimmy johnson and
we we
you know we spoke to tom flores
yesterday and i think he's been waiting
a long time
uh i'm wondering if you could pound the
table for anybody that might think that
other coaches are worthier than uh bill
cower for enshrinement
well here's here's what you have to look
at and
and i think a lot of times you know
people look at
uh hey he's got one super bowl he's got
two super bowls and i get it i
understand that and tom flores i think
he should have been in a long time ago
and but
when i look at a bill cower you look at
the consistency
of of what his career was
he you know him coming in only having
been the head coach for one team and the
career that he
put together uh the consistency the
playoffs
i mean i don't i don't remember
that man i think we maybe had one losing
season maybe two
uh his whole tenure uh and that is
that's rare uh to say that so he's been
he was a motto of consistency you knew
the pittsburgh steelers when you played
them what you were going to get
is going to be physical hardnose and you
know we won the majority of the games
that we played so
uh if you look at you know his track
record at
you know compared to other people it's
gonna it's gonna line
right up uh with all those things yes
he wasn't able to win uh you know the
championship the super bowl that he
that the up the first one he went to and
he lost in a couple of afc championship
games but the key is you put yourself in
that position
time after time uh and so that just
shows you how consistent
he was as a head coach i think he may be
five or six afc championship games
um and so to be that consistent for that
period of time
with totally different rosters you've
got to you got to tip your hat to him
jerome bettis here
on the rich eisen show um what are we
going to get out of big ben this year do
you think
you know that's a great question
hopefully
hopefully we get uh you know
75 80 percent of what the player that
that he has been because you know you
always know that you know he's in the
back of his head he's gonna have a
little
uh a little nervousness about letting it
go uh
full 100 right because whenever you have
that type of injury
that's always in the back of your head
but i believe
you know he has the ability if he's 80
of of himself this is going to be out of
fight team because you already have a
championship caliber defense
that they proved that last year uh
because the defense was the only thing
that kept
the team eight and eight uh just
incredibly but now you add
the receivers that that are in place
that have have really
come out and played well last year then
you bring the running game
uh with the still a solid offensive line
a little bit older but still really good
offensive line
i think you've got a a playoff caliber
team
if ben is 75 of himself if you get ben
back to close to 100
of himself i think you've got a
championship caliber football team so
i think right now the onus is how well
it's been
uh going to be for the entire season and
i think that'll
determine how good this team can really
be i got to tell you man if he is 75
you know the uh the you know more
focused
uh team-oriented ben roethlisberger
where he's not on the
on the radio um and and he's uh you know
more
focused if you will uh on his teammates
in a in a proper way
i'll be very honest here um and
and that happens then that d i i think
you got a top five defense in pittsburgh
you know what i mean i you got t tj
championship caliber defense
no doubt about it i agree i mean tj watt
could be a defensive player to your
candidate just like his bro
uh bud dupree and um on the back end you
got
minker fitzpatrick and we all know the
brains of the operation right there in
the middle
um from an outstanding institution of
higher learning the university of
michigan
and devon bush oh the puppy he's a
youngster he's the younger oh he's
but he's that young i think he's all
groaned up personally
um i think i think that's
you got yourself a serious defense
in pittsburgh you give that defense you
get and that defense
turns people over and gets people off
the field because they sack people
and you give that you give that defense
three touchdowns
offensively you give them two touchdowns
a couple field goals you might have a
you might have a championship caliber
team that's what i'm saying that's i
mean they can they can play against
anybody
in the league and have success and if
they can get the running game going
and ben can can be timely i think i
think
another addition was eric ibron in in
the middle of the field
an area where historically the steelers
have never uh been
very very uh strong at
in in terms of the tight end putting
pressure
vertically and i think if if if brian
can
can bring any of that it brings a
different dimension
that this team has honestly never had
uh and and that can be scary uh jerome
bettis here on the rich eisen show a few
more minutes left
uh with you sir tell me about this uh
virtual youth program designed for
middle-aged
middle school age students obviously
we're in a pandemic many many schools
doing online learning again um walk me
through what this is and how people can
get involved jb
okay well let me just tell you how it
started it started it was crazy i got a
call from from someone in the steelers
organization
and there was a young lady who's a
teacher at training camp
whose kids when everything went to
virtual learning didn't have computers
and so we said you know that that can't
happen
we've got to do something so we one day
we raised about 35
000 for 60 kids to get computers and at
that point we realized that wait a
second we
there's a problem here there's kids who
who are connected they don't have the
connectivity
right so we came up with this program
called connecting kids and
we went out and tried to you know get
with the community and we've raised
money and
we were able to to purchase over a
thousand laptops for kids in south and
southwestern pennsylvania and that was
amazing so we you know that's been
incredible
for for everyone and if anybody wants to
help in that regard because now we're
starting to go to detroit
and then we want to go all over the co
all over the country eventually
and you know people can just go to the
bus stops here foundation.org
or donate to text the bus at 71 777
and that's for the connecting kids part
but then we said hey
we need to provide something because now
our kids are out of school
and they miss some of this learning uh
and so we came up with this check-in
program and basically
we're launching our second uh uh
check-in program this is a second
six-week virtual enrichment session
and it's totally free it's for kids from
age 10 to 14.
all they have to do is go to uh
eventbrite.com to register
it's totally free you've got tech
innovation classes science video
film math zoology entrepreneurship
cyber security marine biology so many
other things
we've got dj on there going and so it's
just uh something that we saw
was an issue now this is for after
school
uh for kids and you know starting at 4
pm eastern
and and so we just wanted to do
something
to help uh during this pandemic and we
saw that there was a
a small problem in terms of
the technology not being affordable and
the internet access
uh it wasn't accessible and that digital
divide
uh was there so we wanted to try to do
something to step in
and try to help with uh you know at-risk
and underprivileged kids who didn't have
that out but don't have the same
opportunities that others do and from
four to five
5 45 p.m uh speaking as a as a
a a parent of three small kids or
three young kids uh an hour and 45
minutes
of time having having uh
you know spending it and getting and
filling their brains with something that
actually expands the mind rather than uh
deadens it is a great idea and it's very
welcome and it's on
mondays and wednesdays eventbrite.com
uh go and search for your name jerome
bettis and uh
and also the bus stops here
foundation.org
is another way to find out all this
stuff um hey man look uh before i let
you go i'm i'm really hoping that uh
notre dame plays football this year you
know why
why well i'm hoping they play football
this year
and i'm careful jerome you're walking
into it you know i'm waiting into it
look jerome bettis i i i don't know
uh his birthday but off the top of my
head but i'm i'm assuming it definitely
isn't august 17th 2020. he wasn't born
yesterday
it was or two days february 16th okay
whatever um he knows when he calls into
the
show i do i do please this is not his
first rodeo
we go way back um so uh the reason why
is you do recall last year uh when our
alma maters
faced off with one another correct do
you remember that i do recall
okay do you recall that when our alma
maters faced off with one another
uh you and i made what we would call a
friendly
wager wager absolutely i don't recall
what i put on the line whatever it was
it was something that i was supremely
confident wouldn't actually happen
right um and as it turns out it didn't
okay so now
you do remember what you have to do
though
because your your school uh lost but if
you recall i came on your show
and i sang your fight song
as a response to that you forget how
quickly we forget
he did that and did we let him off the
hook
this is ringing a bell you're starting
to get up there in age and i understand
i do understand i also went to michigan
but you gotta understand now i i stood
up
and i stood up and you sang the fight
he did i sang a michigan fight song
if you will okay the greatest fight song
no a michigan fight song
and it's something that i i told myself
i would never do
and i did it for you as
payment instead of having to wear that
instead of instead of wearing the hat
because i didn't we thought i thought we
had the hat
there we didn't have the head there and
and because we had it made up and
my business manager forgot it oh yeah
you blamed your people
no he ha we have it i can send you a
picture of it i would love to get a
picture of it okay
i will get you a picture of it i won't
be in the picture
[Music]
because just in case anybody knows
no chance no i did i did
you step up to the plate right and try
to honor
and the hat said what jerome what are
the words i don't remember
i should have gone to michigan you
you're not going to punish me
a second time but that's what you tried
to do well you know what
uh yeah there's no double jeopardy
[Laughter]
[Music]
but forgetful and i did it on national
television
yeah i don't understand i don't know i
don't understand why you never
did go to michigan i mean you're right
there you're you're right there
you're clear it's a better opportunity
for me
at notre dame now so hold on a second
just just to re
recharge this battery is it's because
was it bo was it bo or is it gary moller
or something
let me just tell you for the record put
it on the record what happened okay so
uh-oh did he hang up instead of telling
the story i believe no no just say say
that again
yeah he went to see a running back named
ricky powers
right who was the number one running
back in the in the country
yes in ohio and that's right
that sent shock waves i was a fullback i
was a number one four back in the
country
but it told me the where the where the
importance
was because the the tailback at michigan
is more important than the full back
position
and they were selling me on the fact
that hey we'll play you like leeroy
horde
full back tailback but but i knew once
they
once they signed the number one tail
back in the country
i knew that my opportunities would be
limited
um in terms of running the football
whereas in notre dame
lou holt's offense was based around the
fullback the pullback ran the football
all the screen passes went to the full
back and
when they went to three round receivers
the fullback stayed in the game and he
ran the ball out of a one-back set
so it was a perfect scenario for me to
go to to notre dame because
they actually utilized the fullback much
more
than they did at michigan but but i was
out and you wanted me to play linebacker
okay that was the the first reason you
know what i hear jerome
pullback you know what i hear jerome
instead of instead of uh
uh a tale of woe you know what i hear i
hear that there's a me in jerome and an
eye in betis
that's what i hear you can't spell
betis without an eye and you can't spell
jerome without me
that's what i hear oh no that's valuable
what about me about the case i want to
be the
linebacker i was only five ten i knew i
was only gonna be five
i was i ended up being you know just a
shade under six foot
i knew i was gonna be undersized uh
at linebacker and i was right it it
it paid off for me so i made the right
call
had i went to michigan it would not have
been
the success uh i believe
that would have uh come to me at notre
dame well at least
at least you still have great michigan
ties
and detroit routes to get the ford motor
company fund involved in the jerome
bettis bus
perhaps here foundation launch of the
second session of check-in everyone go
again to eventbrite which is
eventb-r-i-t-e.com
and search for jerome bettis which again
is spelled with an eye in betis
and an me at the end of jerome
i don't believe you i don't believe you
you're the best jb
i love you man rich i appreciate it and
please remember next time i do
things like this to embarrass myself you
could at least remember them
i i appreciate that jerome dennis
dropping the mic out the door there's
jerome bettis
take care hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here